Speaker 1: I have for you today one of the.
Funniest moments from conservative media in
a while. It comes to us from Oann, and they were
doing this fluff piece about Donald Trump. They
were calling him a great president, great
patriot, and they had the sentimental music
going on in the background. It's not even clear
exactly why he was relevant. To be doing right
now is a story. But they were doing it. They were
showing that they have Trump's back for the 2024
election if and when he decides to run. And
right after this sentimental piece they did,
they cut to a commercial break. And what
commercial was it but Viagra to make a really
awkward transition that will go down in television
history. Let's take a look at the clip we hear.
Speaker 2: One America News would like
to say thank you. President Trump,
your legacy as a patriot is unquestionable. You
have inspired countless millions and shown our
nation what it truly means to make America great
again. For one American news, I'm Pearson Sharp.
Speaker 5: Generic Viagra delivered within
48 hours in discreet packaging on approval.
No one will know. But you look and your
mailbox Brexit Indeed.com is the fast,
easy and affordable way to get generic viagra.
Speaker 1: Now that is just the best, isn't it?
That is comedic gold right there, going from
that sentimental news segment right to a Viagra
commercial. And you have to wonder, like, did they
not realize that they were going to be throwing to
a Viagra commercial right away? So the transition
will be a little bit awkward. Did they not realize
that the segment was going to be so heartfelt and
sentimental? Like what exactly went wrong there?
And I feel like with O.J. and you kind of have to
wonder, are they all just trolling us over there
to the right wing commentators on that network?
Are they are they serious or are they just playing
a character? What exactly is going on? Because it
just seems so out there most of the time that you
have to think like they can't actually believe
this stuff. Do they really believe this stuff?
Maybe they are just trolling all of us. And in
terms of transitions being awkward on television,
that probably comes in first place. The one thing
that would maybe rival it, though, is back at the
beginning of the year when Russia had just invaded
Ukraine, there was a lot of coverage of the
war there on CNN. They were showing the sirens
going off at one of the Ukrainian cities,
followed up by a Applebee's commercial. That
really wasn't the best transition either.
Let's take a look at that one.
Speaker 5:
And little bit of chicken fried. So
we're all trying. Apaches are big.
Speaker 1: Just
so you'll all have to tell me which one you
found more awkward. The land transition or
the CNN transition. And to me, it's easier to
laugh at the old one because the CNN clip had
some element of tragedy to it, right. With the war
going on. Whereas the only one you could just take
a look at that and be like, what exactly is going
on at that network? So that's the latest on and
we don't talk about them too much anymore,
but we absolutely had to cover this story.